على كل حال سالنا الناس في مصر كيف يؤثر
نشاطك على مواقع التواصل على صورتك في
العمل نسمحي
[موسيقى]
لي القديم يعني متعودين على العادات معينه
ومش مش يعني مش بنترق للشجر السوشيال
ميديا كثير قوي يعني بتتكرر لها يعني
بسيطه او بنقرا او بنتصفح
عليها حاجه
اصفر فن صور جاهزه مش اكثر يعني همم ما
بتديش ريفلكشن مختلف عن شخصيتي في الشغل
يعني
السوشيال ميديا طبعا ممكن يؤثر على حياتك
اجتماعيه ممكن يؤثر عليك همم ما ينفعش
طبعا همم تشعر اي حاجه لازم تبقى حاذر انت
ممكن تشير النهارده حاجه تتفيد بمنظور
خاطئ مع زميله لك مع زميل لك مع مدير لك
في العمل اي كومنت مش لطيف ممكن ياثر طبعا
لازم اكون دقيق لان انا اكيد قدوه للناس
اللي معي كويس همم لان دوت انعكاس او همم
صورتي قدام الناس اللي انا باشتغل معهم
لازم اكون بشير حاجات
بتفيد الناس حاجات كويسه ما تبقاش الحاجات
ديت خارجه لا اكون دقيق جدا في كل حاجه
باشيرها والله انا بحكم ان انا كبير في
السن ما فيش ما فيش حاجه تقدر تاثر على
شغلي لان شغلي بقى اصيل وثابت ونتائجه
وتحققت بالنسبه ليا لا اطلاقا يعني كده
كده مواقع التواصل اجتماعي ده احنا بس
جاست يعني فني كده شويه وقت فراغ انما كده
كده الواقع العملي حاجه ثانيه خالص
[تصفيق]